- Now is your most recent album 15 years,
after up So tell me about this album
'cause you did
this record all on your own.
This isn't working
with previous writers
or producers you worked
with this is you.
- Yeah, I needed to do something
that was really super independent
musically and creatively
and a song like life's
about to get good.
It's all about optimism
and looking forward to what's next.
And the whole thing was a reminder
that I can do this on my own.
After divorce you it's
a server of so many things.
And you have to find
and rediscover your independence.
- Yeah.
- So this was an exercise
of independence and I've really--
- I've heard people go through that
- It was great therapy.
Well, and also because my ex husband
was my producer,
and my co-writer,
so it was this huge Oh My Gosh!
Every element of my life,
parenting, songwriting,
record-making, partnership,
all of that had to,
I was never alone
in all of that.
- I've never really thought about it
but it's the server
of a lot of ties.
- A lot of things,
so I had a lot of...
and I'd lost my voice.
I had to start over
with my voice.
- Did you like lose your voice physically
or just everything mental emotional,
everything kind of just felt like wow!
- I got Lyme disease
at the end of the up tour.
The vocal cord nerves
were damaged each side
and I had to get
an open throat surgery
not like the cords are fine,
- Okay,
- but they just don't have
the strings, the nerves are just weak.
- Does not have
the same elasticities,
like the same flow.
- They're don't flow symmetrically,
which is an absolute nightmare
for a singer.
So I literally had
to start over
I couldn't hear--
- Girl you were still loaded at once
- I so did yeah.
- That's a lot.
I didn't even know all of that.
- I didn't love life
at that in during that period,
I have to say
but so this is why
life's about to get to get good,
I was like, Okay,
come on, you gotta pick yourself up.
You've got to find
a way to carry on you have to,
'cause you're in this like,
I'm never gonna love again.
I'm never gonna get married again,
- Yeah.
Well, you probably shut down a bit.
It's just for survival.
- Just felt like I have
to start from zero
on so many levels.
But the voice is
been a real triumph.
experience everything has been,
love has been parenting
has been an absolute joy
and my career is,
I'm just living my best life right now.
So I'm not, I don't wanna,
now I love that.
(audience chearing)